[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record we talk about what
we want here oh
sorry oh my god junebe's here
sorry no it's okay you you can you can
still call me timothy
no i feel weird you're not disrespecting
his branding that's totally fine yeah
it's not a yeah it's not a big deal why
change the name it's not a big deal
no it's important it was it was you know
you know yeah people
do you correct fans do people still call
you by your old no you know people can
still call me and i say that in the
video i'm like hey guys you can still
i'm not going to get mad you call me
timothy day like no you're so mad at me
i'm pissed actually i'm gonna talk to
you after this
at least your name's not big ed
he loves that though shout out to be
again then the male hair
i still get uncle sam like every once in
a while i bet
oh they're gonna say every day i don't
know i'm like oh my damn that's so
old but still i still got some og fans
would be like they call me traffic and
[ __ ]
oh yeah traffic your rap alias i totally
forgot what made you
drop traffic completely no one likes
traffic i did yeah well then there's
that
and originally i had traffic as a rap
name and timothy de la ghetto as a
comedy
because i didn't want people to think i
was making comedy rap you were
a childish gambino donald yeah i was
doing that
then what's trey feek trayvik was just a
way to say it
during songs and [ __ ] stephon or kell no
i just thought it sounded cool like
right before i wrapped i'd be like trey
think
but yeah i dropped it because i got i
feel like i got to a point where
people either knew that i was like a
funny person that
also like spit real bars and i didn't
need to like confuse people anymore you
know what i'm saying
because i would have people who are like
oh my god i just realized traffic and
timothy
ghetto are the same person what the [ __ ]
that happened
yeah so yeah but this is actually so now
it's like they're they're both gone and
i'm just tim chatham and i actually like
i finally
have a thing where um uh i'm like it's
on
on like a press like on a release like
tim chatham in this
in this thing now because when does this
come out again i don't know
oh we don't know all right if this come
make this come out after monday so i can
tell you about this new show
okay here okay monday tuesday i'm on
this new mtv show guys
you guys dip into potato chips in a mild
sauce
it's a tweedledee and tweedledump no
uh japanese uh first grade they have
this like
um uh it's like a like a kid kid's a
little it's one of those yeah and then
it's like the red team
versus the white team oh cool
is that for real yep damn he looks cool
like that you look like
[ __ ] what's his name you guys know from
the loch oh the hispanic guy yes
sorry okay we took away from your thing
no it's not a point who's he had a huge
announcement
so yeah your new show you guys know
ridiculousness yeah
so we we we're doing they're doing they
hit me up for a spin-off of
ridiculousness called deliciousness
where it's all food clips
is the star of it no and it's called
deliciousness and where we are you know
reacting to food clips and [ __ ] but
here's the dope
so you're chanel west coast no i'm not
i'm about to laugh
i'm more than sterling i'm more of a
sterling and um but the host
is [ __ ] kelly kapowski from say by
the way
yes bro what does she have to do with
food look have you seen her lately she
likes food
no no no for one for one
she's [ __ ] hot still
i don't even know that i was just
kidding yeah tiffany amber they said
well she dropped the amber it's just
tiffany thiessen now
and she has like a cooking cooking thing
she does like cookbooks and [ __ ] like
that
oh yeah like a chrissy teigen thing
and um and first of all um chia i don't
watch this part but like oh my god she's
still so hot like i'm on set with her
and i'm like oh my god kelly kapow how
close do you get to her
um not close because everything's
distanced and she's over there hosting
and i'm on the couch
but did zach come you met her though
yeah yeah i don't know what we've i've
been
shooting everything yeah oh how close
have i gotten to her oh we've hugged and
everything
dude isn't it crazy that you used to
jerk it to her in the 90s
you mean still jerk it too you know it's
pretty it's trippy because like
so it's a random ass cast it's like but
everyone kind of does food things it's
kelly kapowski or tiffany thiessen
it's angela from the office oh she does
dirt stuff she does food stuff too her
name is andrew
no super nice what the [ __ ] angela and
and kale from keenan and kale
good burger is that his in on the food
is the good burger connect he also does
like his own like sauces like oh okay
okay
the good burger sauce is real yeah yeah
what do you do
and i do a basic to boujee food show and
send food
and i mean on the show i was like
we all just sit and make jokes about the
clips that they show i'm so jealous i
want to meet all those people
so that comes out december 14th on mgv
make sure you check that out that's so
dope you get to be with angela december
14th yeah yeah if you have a million
followers on your instagram and a couple
of shows on the internet i'm pretty sure
you could be on
on as a guest we don't even have guests
no guests sorry
you could be a cash are you cast on the
show thank you for the inspiration
is andrea like really nice in person
yeah cause i thought she was all right
[ __ ]
no she's super nice well she looks like
one off she's a good actress
yeah in the office she's like a total
[ __ ] almost at friendzone actually
uh do you guys see friends funny i like
her forbidden love i think friends is
really funny but
people don't find friends funny i just i
wasn't my i was a kid then
me too it was just wasn't my fault i
watched it when i was a kid as well i
was seven
watching this i remember it was 1997 and
i was seven
watching friends nah i thought keenan
kell was hilarious though
yeah keenan kell was tight i actually
had a crush on kel what what are you
doing with keenan and kelly yeah did you
i did that's why i'm like you want to
meet him you want to meet him
him put put him as your um as your host
okay is it okay sure i want to meet him
too
both of you guys throw me in there both
of you guys put him as your hall pass
how does david feel that you ditched him
now and you're moving up on life
dude um who cares yeah true
now but david has a netflix show he's
about to be on too right yeah
yeah yeah he's he's doing this he's
doing his little thing i guess
whatever how do you guys feel that david
ditched you guys oh that's
that's the truth for send foods
it hurts his feeling that's the answer
yeah i expect him to run away when it
comes to food because he's like
or run towards run away from us toward
food right
right because he you like that yeah he
should have his own show called take
foods
yeah i can see it yeah
that's where that road ended uh so do
are you excited about this like do you
do you
watch yourself on tv and you're like you
get your family and [ __ ]
and like watch mtv at a certain time
well first of all i gotta figure out how
to watch it because i don't currently
have mtv
uh that's funny my cable i watch cable
through hulu and mtv's not on their list
um because i don't use like spectrum
anymore so i gotta figure out how to
watch it
i am just like hook you up well just
like
like i mean yeah well they can send me
links to the episodes but i'd like to
watch it as it's on tv
yeah um you're like a youtuber that
doesn't have youtube premium
i think every youtuber didn't have that
i don't know
[Music]
i guess so i guess i need to i really
want to watch the episodes though
because like
what's dope about this compared to being
all wild and out it's like while now
there's like a [ __ ] castle like 20
people you know i'm saying everyone's
[ __ ] like
grabbing for the mic trying to get their
jokes off this is like it's one of like
three people so i get a lot of screen
time it's
lit you uh have to audition what was
that process like
no i didn't they just hit me up they're
like hey they want to shoot they want to
use you for like a pilot
of this like a ridiculous spin-off and
then we'll see if it works and
apparently they shot like a few
different like variations of
ridiculousness with like different casts
of people and this is the only one that
got picked up for more episodes i was
like
it's really smart you know what's smart
about it is that i feel like nowadays
they just get some bland ass host
and they just do things whereas this
reaches exactly the demo
that you guys are going for food like
not just food but like
you got a 90s icon like for
all the 30 year olds who are watching
this they're all everyone has their
respective demographic
audiences it makes so much more sense to
get all these people yeah even kel too
90s exactly so it'd be like millennial
audience yeah
exactly i was watching i was like oh my
god i have dvd sets of all your guys's
shows this is crazy
did you bring it into getting it signed
um i would totally do that i wore my
save by the bell t-shirt one day though
what did she say she was like oh my god
i love it
that's awesome man do you think she's
tired of that [ __ ] no i mean probably i
think
i [ __ ] evolved every time every time
her phone rings it's about something
saved by the bell
probably no her rings wake up in the
morning
no no no it's not it's not just kidding
i'm just kidding i'm like that's cute
she never let go you know no she's like
no i mean i just mean all those cats
always get called about doing some
reunion show or some other you know the
french friends reunions just gonna bring
that
up did you watch it i did it but i
thought that they did it i saw i saw the
instagram post that uh uh will smith did
with the mom switching out
yeah that was cool i heard it's just a
conversation though they're not actually
doing an episode no it's not scripted
it's a whole like
it's a conversation at the old house at
the old set they recreated the whole set
and [ __ ] man it's dope like two
minutes and she was already like bawling
yeah what is it on baseball prime i
don't got no none of that [ __ ]
hp prime no hbo mad i was like
yeah amazon amazon hbo work together
hbo max yeah yeah it's a it's dope they
do this whole thing like of course
talk about uncle phil everyone cries he
does a whole interview with like the
original mom who he hadn't spoken to in
like 30 years
yeah they had like a lot of beef will
smith and the original mom had beef
yeah but before we talk about the beef
let me tell you about something right
now that's on all of our minds
today's video is brought to you by
upstart and there's a lot of economic
chatter going on right now
about the state of the market we can't
be watching saved by the bell we can't
be watching fresh prince of bel air
because
we're wondering is it gonna recover
is the economy gonna crash who knows i
don't know
but if you're struggling to pay off your
high interest credit card debt you can't
wait for those answers
you need to take action now with upstart
there's actually something you can do
today to help fight off high
interest credit card debt upstart is the
revolutionary
online lending platform that knows
you're more than just a credit score
and upstart makes it fast and simple to
check your rate since it's just a soft
pull
it won't affect your credit score the
hard pull happens if you accept your
rate and proceed with your application
the best part if the loan is approved
and accepted most people
get their funds the very next business
day which is very very fast
over 500 000 people have used upstart to
pay off credit cards or meet their
financial goals and you can too
free yourself from the burden of high
interest credit card debt and get back
to using your money
your way with upstart and see why
upstart has over 6
000 five-star reviews on trustpilot so
hurry
to upstart.com record to find out how
low your upstart rate can be
checking your rate only takes a few
minutes that's upstart.com
record r-e-c-o-r-d your loan amount will
be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application
not all applicants will qualify for the
full amount
so the uncle phil and on viv the
original
had beef no no whale phil smith and the
original mom had beef
yeah and then that's why they had to
replace her yeah the original aunt viv
didn't like will smith because
he was being like a young 20 something
like all uh big-headed and stuff
and aunt vib was like yo chill out and
then will didn't like that but he was a
big enough star to get her booted off
wow
there's a whole thing oh dude that's the
skinny of it i don't know if he admitted
it what happened he admits he's like yo
look honestly i was 20 years old
i didn't know janet hoover yeah herbert
he's like i didn't know what was going
on with you he just i just knew that
like
what what i saw whatever and she's like
you know you have no idea
and you also didn't ask she was pregnant
like she got fired after the season when
she was pregnant
oh she was like you don't know what's
going on she's like i i was dealing with
an abusive marriage i was doing this so
there's a reason why like
i would come to set i just didn't feel
like talking to people and she basically
she's like she's like dude you have no
idea she's like i lost
everything because of the words you said
to get me off the show what did he say
well i like the the whole thing was they
were saying you recorded that and put it
up
yeah and he's like like so back then he
was saying that
she was difficult to work with and she's
like do you have any idea
the effect that that has on a black
woman especially a dark-skinned black
woman for you to say
with your stature in the industry tell
the industry that i'm difficult to work
with
she's like i lost everything and then
they picked the lighter skin
actress to take over stephanie maxwell i
didn't even know there was a switch
because i was so young what really i
needed to do they looked totally
different
i was like wait i wasn't that die hard
of a fan to notice because you know
you don't watch every single episode
sometimes you miss one and then
you know here's here's what i didn't get
until i got older on the season where
they came back and they made the switch
because they didn't acknowledge it at
all until
they did acknowledge it because [ __ ]
jazz
jazz was like in the living room as the
new mom is like dusting and [ __ ]
and jazz is like you know um
there's something different about you oh
but i just i can't put my finger on it
and will kind of like looks at the
camera breaks the fourth wall wow and
he's like i got
fired oh [ __ ] what did he say to that
he was like so you to be honest when i
watched i was expecting him to like
full out be like i'm so sorry about that
like but he was he was more being like i
was 20.
um i didn't know what you were going
through uh
and he does apologize towards the end of
it they both kind of mutually apologize
because they had both like talked a lot
of [ __ ] about each other
um but yeah it was it was crazy you
could you could tell that she really
wanted to almost
like go in more on like you
[ __ ] ruined my life you know what i'm
saying but she was really kind of
holding it together
and like forgave him and they hugged and
that's good that's really good because
like they said they like we literally
like they hug
they're like wow it's been a long time
like 27 years and you should have been
like
and here's 10 million dollars yeah right
oh i thought it was going to be like
and this is why i told everyone you're
difficult so
go away for another 20 years hey you're
being very difficult right now
seeing that switch on instagram like
will's post is that
janet looks like she didn't age one like
at
like one year at all like she looks
identical the bimbo sister
no the original one original mom oh
the actress name she didn't she didn't
age at all and i was like what did she
time travel to get to this reunion
that's [ __ ] crazy
well some will say that black don't
crack i've never heard that
yeah i've heard that yeah that's true i
need to see it dog you should watch it
find a way to watch it it's [ __ ]
tight
yeah yeah where do you watch it on hulu
hbo
hbo max yeah okay yeah i have that
i'll go look yeah dog watch it yeah
especially i mean i was such a die-hard
fresh prince fan you know what i'm
saying so it's like
tatiana ali was always my favorite and i
loved her more because her
her name started with the t and i didn't
know a lot of girls that had started
with tea
and i was like i love it and then her
her voice is so
beautiful i liked carlton he's the best
he's so funny
[Music]
but then he did it on so many different
late night shows and he did it on
dancing with the stars it was a little
accessible
well of course and it just became
something where i just started to feel
bad for him
sad for him as well is he known for
anything else at all
he's good at dancing yeah he's good at
dancing right
was he a backup dancer for michael
jackson he was he was on the pepsi
commercial with michael jackson what
his middle name is abraham lincoln
alfonzo abraham lincoln ribeiro
what [ __ ] i wonder why you didn't put
that in the titles
because it's distracting he hosted
america's funniest home videos for yeah
he did he's a talented kid okay oh he
was great enough
and dance and he's funny he was the
perfect nerd and he you could tell too
because
will really couldn't act on that show if
you could tell in the beginning
will's just being wilson how good was
will though when he had to do that uncle
phil
scene the doctor i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna ruin the moment
for you but they talk about that that
specific scene
and how much he wanted to impress uncle
phil because uncle feels like trained
shakespearean like actor and [ __ ]
and i just watched it dude it's so tight
my favorite was
when they're at the pool hall and then
um uncle phil comes in he goes
jeffrey break out lucille yeah yeah but
alfonso was such a good actor i mean
everybody on that show was a good actor
and then will kind of
grew as the show it got better one thing
that's dope they showed on the reunion
is um
because will was such a like he was so
new to everything that he would memorize
like everybody's lines right because he
was so nervous and there's episodes
the early ones and you never notice
until they show you because they zoom up
on will's mouth and he's mouthing
everyone's lines
as they're doing it the only way he
could do his lines
so it's like actual like [ __ ] like
he'll say his line and then it'll be
other person's talking he's like
and then he'll say his lines he's crazy
that's funny
and it's so interesting to see like
behind the scenes stuff of the stuff
that you love
it's really interesting he's been famous
since 20.
yeah can you imagine watching
independence day without will smith is
the star of it
oh no it just doesn't work i don't know
i don't know if anybody has that kind of
gravitas
because he he won a grammy even before
the show already right he would start as
a rapper first
rapper yeah yeah yeah yeah damn he so he
made him he was like 19 probably 18 19.
yeah cause when they were having that
conversation of him being 20 that was
already in the third season of fresh
prince
he's a teenager then he started in 1990
fresh prince
it aired in 1990 he was born in 68
through the match
21 two he's just been successful the
last
50 years that's crazy yeah
1990 and then he started a youtube
channel and that was popping off
right from the beginning now he's a
[ __ ] tick tock instagram star
too damn yo i remember ashley banks was
like one of my first like crushes on tv
aside from uh kelly kapowski
and uh and so dante bosco he did a movie
uh called faking the funk right with
with tatiana lee ashley banks that's
like the love interest
and years later after me and dante had
already become cool then like
you know like i had his number and [ __ ]
i randomly texted him i was like
dude you made out with ashley banks
because that they had a kissing scene in
that movie
and i just remember being like bro
that's so cool
and he's just like oh yeah you know yeah
yeah we're cool i was like
wow it's just part of acting yeah it's
still so cool
that is cool maybe you get to make out
with kelly kapowski on the show or dante
she's married it's acting tip it's
acting dude zack morris got to make out
with kelly kapowski in the 90s
that's the best i wish i wish he was in
my phone where's zach morris
would you be down and kiss dante's
lipstick i did when he was on pockets i
licked his mouth and i was like oh
there's a reboot of fresh pr of uh save
by the bell not reboot it's
um there's a new saved by the bell
coming out on peacock
and it looks so funny it's it's um the
writers of 30 rock
and and it's like mario lopez is the
principal cool
and bruh it looks [ __ ] fun zach is
the governor now california
yeah yeah yeah it looks so good the
original zach morris is now the governor
what the [ __ ] i didn't see the trailer
though i just saw mr baldwin's still
alive it's a building
yeah yeah he's still alive let's watch
this you should be the principal it
looks funny bro
it's only a minute 48. sorry doctors
in attendance will be the governor
i don't care about your dad spencer i
just care about zach and kelly
we all want these new kids to feel
welcome
can we talk did you just sit backwards
in a chair
in real life it's not gonna work unless
we get to know them
you only know how bayside works for kids
like you hot kids
privileged kids privileged kids
this place ever stop being weird a one
two three
the old gang back together again isn't
it
not sure
[Music]
will you go to dinner with me stop
eavesdropping we're not we're the base
side of the acapella group
[Applause]
[Music]
wait was that jessie strano yeah
yeah dude didn't even show kelly what
the [ __ ] she's not in it
or maybe it's a surprise what's peacock
is that a new yeah it's nbc's streaming
service yes yes wait kelly's in it
that's what i'm saying i didn't see
kelly what's busy filming uh oh
deliciousness i i pointed toward her i
was like because this is her
didn't let her talk maybe it's a big
reveal her episode
yeah wait where's screech oh well
in rehab i think have you heard the news
no i i thought he did porn he stabbed
the guy
and i think he's yeah and i think he
wrote a tell-all book about how they all
are [ __ ] and yeah i don't think he's
gonna be involved yeah i think they [ __ ]
with dustin diamond right
yeah he said that all of the kids were
[ __ ] he said they're all [ __ ]
because he was a nerd yeah of course
they're gonna [ __ ] with him and he was
younger than everybody
yeah i mean like on the show they're
gonna bully him and off the show they're
method actors you [ __ ] nerd yeah you
[ __ ] nerd you know what sucks is no
lisa turtle dude
what happened to lisa i don't know she
isn't she's an actor anymore
she's kind of going through some like
some [ __ ] too in her real life i think
did she kiss dante too
no but she's right here too
oh yay oh okay oh yeah she looks good
i think jessie looks better stuff you
ever seen show girls yeah
i've seen the inside of her [ __ ] yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you